ces 8 a remporté cinq trophées et je
vous demande d'applaudir le président de
séville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors franck j'aimerais que tu pars tu
n'est peut-être pas ce que tu as ça va
être très long si tu donnes des notes à
tout le monde
est-ce que sa valorisation globale de la
chaîne et certains chroniqueurs ce soir
anne nivat est avec nous en plus ce
soir-là d'or lahouel serait bien de chez
nous et n'ont certes pas jo elle serait
bien chez moi mais c'est bien alors
excellente saison vraiment sincèrement
c'est une très bonne saison de tvnp très
solide très drôle
il ya la meilleure progression pour moi
de l'année c'est benjamin castaldi ce
que l'année dernière je t'aurais minott
épouvantable cette année magnifique le
vendredi non non c'est pas facile
ces bons est vraiment voilà je trouve
que tu as fait une super saison
et en plus il a fait un truc cette
saison on s'y attendait pas du tout il a
ouvert les yeux et articulé ouvert les
yeux et articulé et on se demander
qu'est ce qui lui manquait en fait
c'était juste ça non sincèrement l'année
dernière ont rayé parce que tu
présentais les choses à contre-courant
c'est la cousine qui donnent tous qui
danse toujours même sur du disco à
contresens à cette année non seulement
tu es dans le rythme mais c'est vraiment
très bien donc tu es la meilleure
progression
alors mesdames christine géraldine la
classe incarnée
voilà c'est je me demande presque
pourquoi vous êtes là mais c'est
[Rires]
violent mais l'intelligence et le recul
j'appelle m6 pour savoir si je peux
venir une année avant je guéris bah
écoute vraiment chez europe ce soir
toute la table aujourd'hui parce que je
te préfère là je pense que tu as fais
pas une excellente saison des eps faut
savoir un les votes et les trophées du
meilleur animateur de la décennie c'est
des centaines de milliers de gens qu'ils
votent c'est pas tomber c'est vraiment
des votes massifs et populaire ce plus
de trois cent quarante mille personnes
ont voté pour toi donc félicitations est
vraiment tu as su se faire une place
oppose cette table et je sais que c'est
pas facile il y en a qu'on n'a jamais
plus revu au budget il si on force
jamais vu c'est fini ça celui qui fait
la photo maintenant fera l'émission on a
vraiment une excuse mais l'émission
s'appelle ben aziz avec ce match où tu
vois là c'est la bonne humeur incarner
elle a beau se prendre du chocolat
longueur d'année enfin surtout ces
derniers temps ce pas longueur d'année
non plus haut mais voilà c'est la joie
de vivre c'est le rythme c'est une vraie
journaliste médias donc excellentes
notes repos à pau isabelle jean michel a
vraiment saison remarquable tu serais
même une de mes meilleures notes
après je te soupçonne depuis toujours tu
le sais de ne rien faire du tout
aussitôt que la moyenne on va dire mais
tous avec élégance
félicitations d'objets nico c'est mon
coup de coeur de l'année
je t'ai adoré dans l'art astra iv mais
vraiment voilà les valeurs qu'il a
défendu sa mama sam à février le coeur
donc merci d'être là tu est
indispensable aujourd'hui à l'émission
selo nivea crème de l'émission ouais et
matthieu delormeau et un excellent
producteur animateur chez très bon
tajine une excellente saison aussi on
n'en parle pas mais ça tout petit peu la
voilure
parce que la star c'est lui mais
ouais mais l'appareil excellente saison
élément indispensable
autour de cette table maxime je les ai
connus journalistes et d'y habiter en
tant que patron de shell et baïda
retourner à l'école maxime sera là
l'année prochaine
oui alors c'est le charme d'une autre
époque
bah c'est ça beaucoup de l'intemporel
oui je pense que j'aurai beaucoup plus à
ma grand-mère décédée la sphère sa
gueule j'ai oublié raymond ah oui c'est
souvent le plein et raymond non alors
vraiment une pareille révélation total
stade du bon sens tu parle vrai voilà je
tape aussi énormément de toute façon
vous le savez je vous apprécie tous
c'est très clair est ce que vous avez
une question à lui poser peut-être sur
l'année prochaine ou parce que le patron
il a il réglait encore trois minutes
alesi ou bien dit plus que si vous avez
quelque chose à lui dire oui a dit baala
pour le moment vous avez donné les
appréciations de tout le monde mais moi
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous pensez de
cyril bon vous avez peur de lui ou anti
régime et des dix patrons trop
perfectible a fait livrer des costumes
sublimes je n'ai pas essayé mais ils ont
l'air très beau nom mais les freins non
ben oui non la coiffure
non tout va assez bien la couleur
peut-être non mais c'est une énorme
chance je le dis à jeudi à longueur
d'année aux journalistes qui me disent
mais s'il ne fait pas trop de ces huit
cyril hanouna dépendant je suis fier
d'être à nous la dépendance je souhaite
à toutes les chaînes du monde d'avoir un
producteur et un animateur comme cyril
c'est pour moi à ce génie du
divertissement
personne ne te la même chose vraiment
juste à écouter et j'ai buté parole nous
sommes entièrement d'accord là dessus
voilà quand on a la chance de travailler
actional moon a conquis bravo
non